we've got 12 hours until the
Enlightenment people will become curious
again have I will be there to teach them
I cannot do this by myself
train us bring us into flash time with
you we're not ready to use flash time we
deserve to make the choice to be a hero
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new flash to talk about a
little bit of finale in some flash war
so we'll work through all that in that
order but if you're finding me for the
first time it is the end of the flash
season but there's a lot of flash war
stuff heating up so be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos this is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway - all
you have to do tend to that it just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so the big thing with this week's
episode the trailer basically just tells
you that he tries to take the team into
flash time Devo goes to Argus to get the
nuclear man which is where they've been
stashing him to activate his
enlightenment device like they say
t-minus 12 hours to the Enlightenment so
it sounds like he activates the device
using fallout because you see that green
gas filled the chamber inside Argus and
he says let there be light but it just
takes the course of that 12 hours to
ramp up to a hundred percent it will hit
that in the finale but you can kind of
see how they're using flash time as a
concept for a couple of these big things
like the whole idea seems like that the
thinker actually does activate the
device in the finale in a lot of their
final battle takes place in a really
weird inception II flash time way if you
didn't hear it a couple weeks ago the
producers said that the finale would be
very inception II now that could mean a
couple different things because
inception is all about traveling through
the layers of people's minds they could
have been talking about it in that way
they could just be talking about the
really cool way that they use powers
within people's minds in Inception like
the way you see the city folding it on
itself
crazy matrix like mine space powers
because the comic book thinkers story
had a very matrix spin on it where they
were fighting each other inside the
thinker's mine but it was kind of a
digital space it was released around the
time that the Matrix movie came out so
it was a little bit more like that
inception has less of a digital spin on
it it just literally inside someone's
mind
but because of the way that thinker has
been absorbed being minds a lot of
people have been asking how does Ralph
Dib nee come back this doesn't make
sense it's all probably happening in
some crazy mind space era I don't think
that it involves a lot of time travel
which I've seen a lot of people put
forth as theories for how everything is
solved in the finale just remember they
said Inception II they didn't say
anything about time travel so lean more
into mind space as to how they
accomplish that remains to be seen
because we haven't seen Barry go into
any kind of mind space plays but that
could have something to do with the we
are the flash finale title in like
giving himself over to the thinker if
you remember the end of the Matrix
movies he'll out Agent Smith to absorb
him then defeated him from the inside
that might have something to do with the
flash finale but just keep your mind
open
we'll make as many thinker puns as
possible but to think that they did not
put in the trailer though that they did
have in the pictures was Diggle because
he's working for Argus right now
remember last season around this time
they went to orcas it was a king shark
episode with a Captain Cold crossover
but Lyla was the arrow guest star that
popped up so we'll see how much Diggle
does during this episode but he's inside
STAR Labs in these pictures so it sounds
like they call him in before they try to
infiltrate Argus so minor arrow
crossover we also probably get a T up
for Marley's helping team flash out
because she is in the episode but she's
nowhere in the teaser or remember the
whole thing this season is that it's
supposed to be a villain that Barry
can't just beat with his SuperSpeed
so that's why I think this is building
towards a mind Palace battle I have
gotten a lot of questions about Season
five villains lately people have been
asking me if I think that it's gonna be
cobalt blue or cicada I wasn't exactly
sure why everybody thought that this
might be the case until I did a little
digging and it turns out the reason why
is there's a rumor that there's a
lightning bolt dagger that they use at
the end of the flash season four finale
the way they use the Jay Garrick helmet
at the end of the flash season one so it
let you know oh hey Jay Garrick's coming
next season
what the hell is that that's my cue to
leave
so right now there's a rumor that
there's a lightning bolt dagger that
shows up at the end of the flash season
4 I haven't been able to find out where
this rumor started but there's only a
couple people in the comics that wield
weapons like that so that's why people
think that it might be cobalt blue or
cicada for next season so no worries I
will do flash season 5 villain videos
once we get some more concrete
information but if that doesn't have to
be true I do have a couple of ideas of
how they could twist a Daniel West story
into that but we'll just wait for a
little more evidence so no worries but
moving into flash war territory if you
have no idea what that is that's like a
the really big comic book flash event
that's happening this year it's starting
with the next issue they teed it up this
past week by revealing what happened to
hunter zolomon who's sort of like the
main villain of flash war right after
flash rebirth so if you're not a big
comic book reader what happened is is
that during the Wally West era hunter
zolomon was the main reverse flash he
just called himself zoom so what
happened is is when Barry Allen came
back during Geoff Johns flash rebirth
after that story they took down hunter
zolomon zoom character put him in iron
Heights prison but his cell happened to
be very close to EU barred thawne's and
he said I think that we can help each
other and they just kind of went away
that was the teaser they gave you in
that we didn't find out what happened to
him after that
so for rebirth flash war they went back
to this moment to explain what he's been
doing this whole time and what happens
is the eobard thawne comes from the 25th
century rescues him from prison fixes
things so that he can walk again
they try to form an evil supergroup
based around hunter zolomon principles
for how you make the flash better so the
reason why he was a villain
is because he was pushing Wally to be
better but he was doing it in a really
psychotic way by making him experienced
tragedy he doesn't know tragedy like I
do he can only be a better hero if he
understands so he's like this really
toxic fan of Wally he wants to make him
better but in the worst way possible
eobard thawne says that i've failed to
defeat the flash so many times that i'm
gonna listen to hunter zolomon plan but
they come to blows and he's like i can't
take this anymore
i'm gonna go back and do things myself
that's when he gets killed
dr. Manhattan which happened earlier
during flash rebirth last year so you
Bart dawn is a casualty of the big
Doomsday Clock dr. Manhattan stuff
that's going on at the DC Universe
hunter zolomon stayed in the 25th
century they took control of what they
call the time courts because time travel
is regulated in the future they co-opt
the rogues of the future the renegades
and they start messing with time a
little bit to try and make the flash
better so hunter zolomon is driving the
flash family to fight each other and
that will become the flash war he wants
ginger wally west to fight barry allen
ginger Wally West is in the middle of
regaining all these pre new 52 memories
so he's going a little bit crazy but
obviously that's just the tease to sell
the comics it's not like they're gonna
fight each other because they hate each
other
Wally West and Barry Allen are the best
of friends they're flash family there's
gonna be some other big twist so what'll
happen is is when that drops I'll do
videos for it it seems like it's gonna
be pretty cool I'm a really big fan of
what they've been doing with the flash
characters in the comics lately they
also roped in godspeed he's also being
influenced by a mystery figure that says
that he can help him correct the
mistakes of his past but it's an
off-screen voice we're not meant to find
out yet it just sounds like they're
gonna be involving all the biggest flash
characters in this flash war event and
zoom is meant to be the main antagonist
so it should be pretty cool if you're
not a big comic book reader I would
recommend that you check it out and if
you don't read comics you don't know
where to start
just start with flash rebirth you should
be fine congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last video how to vegan
and to answer your question yes I will
do it Thanos fortnight video there's a
lot of like funny crossover stuff
happening right now there'll be more
Deadpool today too
click here for my flash episode video
from last night and click here for brand
new infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight